Two out of 10 Europeans create one, which
means you really have to
convince people and do a lot of development work,
but 10 out of 10 Europeans have a
current account and perhaps the customers who
only come to us for the card are people who
want to flex with our card
This merror card yes and
even if you don't want to
get this 1% safe pack you have to
create a savings plan and if you
use this card for a year and flex then
you will somehow get a savings and
maybe then start
this plan journey with us  to start and
that is of course a
very exciting measure for us to simply increase the
addressable market fivefold overnight
and the imagination is already
there